two
hello everybody this is um
foot
general in arms foot well not arms that
doesn't make sense foot general and feet
i mean it's redundant
i'll work on that
this is ethan klein off the rails with
ethan klein without ela podcast welcome
everybody
today's episode is sponsored by my wife
teddy fresh everybody this new
collection
comes out on the 22nd of this month
so stand by and follow teddy fresh on
instagram no
when the new stuff's coming out how's
everybody doing today
pretty
good
yeah doing well
did you guys hear that harvey weinstein
is going blind and losing teeth in
prison oh poor guy oh
i was my my reaction was like anyway
[Music]
it's like they it's like they
the lawyers keep trying to make him
sound like this pathetic little weasel
in prison and
nobody feels bad everyone's just like
uh-huh that's
that's awesome we love to hear it
tell me more about his suffering his
lawyers i don't know what they're
playing they want him they want him to
like
not get extradited to la because he's
got like a billion more charges in la
dude this guy was racking james charles
numbers weinstein
he's really prolific
they're trying to get they're trying to
prevent him from being extradited to la
to stand for like 18 additional charges
and he's already in jail for like
a long ass time maybe probably even
got i don't know 20 years plus
so i guess he's comfy in new york
because he didn't want to go
but um uh my heart goes out to weinstein
and his family
poor guy's gone blind
did you all hear that uh um katy perry
says her latex look on american idol may
cause dress farts
so we'll definitely be looking forward
to that i don't know why wendy williams
didn't try that that was my dress
[Music]
she didn't think to get a latex one yeah
just it was a dress fart
we'll be listening very closely katie so
this is the new dress apparently well i
mean how many times she planning on
wearing the dress how many times can you
wear a dress
she can wear it every episode i'll get
it
she got like a whole fleet of latex
straps dresses i mean what is this
how's the dress cause a fart
i mean i guess cause it's just gonna
squeak a lot why
yeah why would you pre-announce this
she knows she's gonna be ripping ass bro
she's already covering her tracks
wendy williams could learn something
from katy perry she's on another level
of farting on air
it's the latex
all right today's gonna be a bit of a
foot soldier army day
i'll be honest with you guys
i'm pretty fired up food soldiers
it's not good it's not as good when
ela's not here to look at me like cringe
because then it's like too serious
wake up
but [ __ ] it dude
it's time to take some wikifeeds boys
does alex jones have a wiki feed that's
a really good question
dude
does alex jones have a wiki feat
it's not funny
oh there's a female named alex jones
and she has a really good rating
i don't even know who that is
just she does have
yo that's crazy to be
another celebrity named alex jones how
do you live your life like that
wow did you feel bad for her
alex jones
wikifeed alex jones mim
i sent him the discord oh he's already
got brutalized eh just one photo
he looks good come on guys look at that
body
this is your body on alpha brain
or he makes like gorilla brain or some
[ __ ]
dogs with me baby
yeah
so why does he do that man trying to get
a close-up of his damn feet god he's got
such a body dude he's such a thickly
cast
brawny dude
never forget alex jones before and after
can you send me that and discard it's
one of my favorite things ever
you guys you guys know alex jones owner
of infowars i mean tricia didn't know
who he was which kind of blew my mind so
i don't know if i need to explain who he
is or not
but infowars did a whole there's i've
been the subject of like tons of
conservative media
recently as like the pinnacle of stupid
libtard fascism
because of a tweet i made
so i'm gonna i'm going to um
basically respond to other videos and
explain the situation you guys
it should be fun because
these people are just
they set me off on twitter because their
take is so [ __ ] dumb
um and now they've they've made videos
about it which is even more fun to react
to so
um
i am looking forward to that this is
alex jones special
thank you uh thank you mr president
this is alex jones he was trying to sell
supplement because that's like his whole
shtick as he sells like supplements with
like
he sells them with like uh
lead and asbestos and [ __ ]
45 days it's supposed to be a weight
loss right
or muscle building or
oh is it supposed to be muscle building
i mean regardless so 45 days later
he literally just looks redder
it's crazy they took this photo and
thought they were doing something with
it
yeah alex jones business model is wild
he just sells like snake oil supplements
you can't trust walgreens or cvs you
gotta trust me at alexjones84.com
he makes like minute he makes like
normal [ __ ] too like metamucil he's like
we make we make men amusable we don't
use the [ __ ] ingredient we use like
rat droppings
grass
that turned the freaking frogs gay yeah
he's a character man
anyway
wasn't alex jones who um
responded was one of his lackeys but
they're just very disappointing oh
there's like a whole meme on this
yeah someone tried to correct the colors
on it to show that he looks exactly the
same if he wasn't tan in the second one
i mean he looks exactly the same i don't
need a color correction
you know what i mean
pretty much
i love that
that's me trying to lose weight by the
way that's like a meme me trying to lose
weight 45 days later
looks exactly the same so let me explain
this whole situation
now people say oh i i don't see this as
me being political this is me
i mean these are issues that i don't
believe should be political and a lot of
in a lot of other countries are not or i
would say all other countries are not
political issues
being smart about getting vaccinated
being smart about covid safety
these are not political issues these are
public safety issues you know what i
mean like
this is just good governance
uh logical
um so there's there was
there's been talks about uh vaccine
passports now that the vaccine's been
rolling out a lot
the way i understand the vaccine
passport is that
if you're going to like big the only way
that people like doc let's say dodger
stadium here in l.a or any other sports
stadiums
movie theaters
you know uh venues live shows stuff like
that the only way these places can
safely reopen
and regain public trust
is for people to show that they proof a
vaccination
i don't think right right i mean that's
it that's a vaccine passport
people say oh well i i don't think it's
going to apply to places like grocery
stores although i'm sure it's up to the
specific chain if they want to check
someone's if they've been vaccinated or
not i mean that's just the free market
that all these people champion
yeah i think in in most cases what
they're talking about is
businesses having
as their own policy
the requirement to show some sort of
proof of vaccination
i think there's
yeah and and of course you know
republicans are all about big business
making making their own decision and
making their like
who are they to regulate a business and
tell them what they can and can't do you
know what i mean
that's their whole argument
so anyway this guy goes i don't know who
the [ __ ] this guy is justin amash i i i
laughed at this [ __ ] he goes he's a
politician uh right wing he was very
anti-trump um one of the few on the
right that were i think
i can't recall if he was a republican
and left or he never was but he's now
independent and styles himself as a
libertarian yeah
he goes no vaccine passport it doesn't
get much more dystopian than being
required to show your health papers
wherever you go bro there are way more
dystopian things in the world
i was like it doesn't get more dystopian
than that it gets so much more dystopian
than that yeah you know in china they're
scanning people's faces and giving them
social points and if they don't have
enough social points they can't ride
public transportation bro like
your imagination is not very
robust if you think it doesn't get more
dystopian than having a [ __ ] health
showing if you've been vaccinated after
a [ __ ] pandemic [ __ ]
do you have your passport our kelly been
r kelly been singing about that decades
ago
why you think he's asking his girls did
you get your shots because you have to
be vaccinated to immigrate to america
my wife
[Music]
dude r kelly is like
he gets it bro where's our kelly when
you need him
do you have your passport i've been
getting girls i've been getting girls
vaccinated since decades ago baby
they don't let they don't allow my girls
in from nigeria unless they vaccinated
did you get your passport did you gotta
get your shots the fact that
the fact that that meme we've been doing
on the show for years is about vaccines
and passports
it's just it's too perfect i can't
believe dude r kell i'm just saying like
it's not rocket science but i i just
couldn't get over this guy because it
doesn't get more dystopian than that i
was like seriously
that's your the limit of your
imagination for dystopian
1984
brave new world
just showing if you've been vaccinated
okay
these people are so long i don't even
get the whole argument they have about
like oh past uh this uh vaccine
passwords are fascism like what why are
they so opposed to proving if you've
been vaccinated i don't even get those
premise
well like i know they say it infringes
on personal freedom but like
okay a lot of [ __ ] do like you can't
just like you can't just go murder
someone so are we saying that infringes
on your personal freedom i mean like
what are you talking about
covet 19.
yeah i mean they're acting as if this is
a
a vaccine mandate um you know
trying to
force everybody to get the vaccine but
it's so but it's not at all so are they
just right it's using the market to
incentivize it it's like you know giving
businesses an option to
deny
their services on the basis of uh
by the way it's not even it's it's a
it's a
it's an indirect incentive because these
private companies are going to make the
decision for themselves if they want
their people to be vaccinated or not
it's like it's not a mandate by the
government
no vaccine passport
you all can go [ __ ] party with each
other like all you non-vaccinated
[ __ ] can go have you actually no
that's the problem you see
the whole premise of
misinformation
is incredible
i don't want to get into it now because
i'm going to respond to all these videos
but
don jr of course who is the biggest
[ __ ]
goon really i mean donald jr god i'd
rather be anyone i'd rather be weinstein
than donald jr
he is a legend pretty sure donald jr
wishes his he was anybody but don't yeah
exactly
vaccine passports communist china will
be proud of democrats recent push my
thoughts bro get a [ __ ] brain cell
please
communist china do you know the kids
need to be vaccinated go to kindergarten
you dip [ __ ]
your kids are vaccinated and they had to
show proof to go to kindergarten you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
communist china shots exactly listen r
kelly's been saying that for decades
there's a reason that society you know
when a bunch of humans clump together
in cities like millions of us yeah you
know new york city the place you came
from place like that wouldn't be
possible if we didn't have vaccines bro
and people didn't get them
[ __ ] miracle of science dude that we
even have vaccines and these guys are
[ __ ] too brain dead to even realize
the latest liberal plan is this a
liberal plan i don't see i don't see of
like an organized democratic push saying
oh we need vaccine passports is this a
conversation that's even happening yeah
it was yeah
but i mean
i think biden shot the whole idea down
so it's all it's kind of moot at this
point
wasn't that great of a plan
i haven't heard anything it didn't get
very far i've only heard about it from
them honestly
but again it's like you got to make up
your mind are you are you no regulation
or are you no vaccine passport because
you can't [ __ ] you know what i mean
businesses want to make people
vaccinated they have that right
according to you until it infringes on
your supposed rights then they don't you
[ __ ] hypnotize got to get it straight
for once
the truth is they just drumming up
controversy for clicks i don't think
anyone really give a [ __ ]
listen to john jr in the jungle look at
look god what is with him look how hard
he's trying to be his dad oh he's
starting junior here so today
when did you start doing this recently
he's really kicked up the the the daddy
impersonation he is such a deeply sad
person is so [ __ ] crazy it's crazy to
me that people um
there's people that like
apparently there's people that like him
i love it
not donald
oh my
god oh
god
i know stories about goon all the
stories from his childhood of how
[ __ ] abusive and crazy his dad was to
him and now he's just like this
pathetic [ __ ] imitation of him oh it
is kind of tragic i do feel bad for him
in that way deeply tragic i mean learn
about like
apparently he hated his dad and he
didn't want to have anything to do with
him in college
what's the story about
he didn't show up in a suit to a plane
his dad like slapped him or something no
not to a play to a baseball game his dad
showed up at his college was going to
take him to assume a yankees game
um
and this is all a story from uh
don junior's um roommate in college
and supposedly uh
yeah he showed up and he was just
dressed in normal clothes and his and
his dad decked him
like punched him yeah you should have
known better
everybody wear suits to ball games
he supposedly filled a suit
to a [ __ ] baseball game
so yeah i mean not a happy childhood i'm
sure
i mean how could it be his dad his dad
is [ __ ] donald trump it's just like
oh are you kidding me
yeah and so he like ran away after
college or he like moved to colorado and
tried to you know be his own man daddy
cut him off
yeah and he got cut off and uh realized
he couldn't make it so he came crawling
back and reinvented himself as just a
mirror image of his dad but look now
he's got like uh
he's got a girl he's got people that
like him his daddy maybe even said a few
nice words to him and now he's doing all
this i mean things couldn't get better
for donna oh god don jr anyway let's
watch this i'm gonna come
today we're gonna talk the vaccine
passport concept and everything about
that i put out a tweet the other day
that sort of went viral and it sort of
went viral let me get this straight some
democrats want american citizens to have
a vaccine passport to travel freely with
the united states but not an id to vote
clowns
well one is a [ __ ] deadly pandemic
that's highly contagious and killed 500
000 people
and then the other i mean there they
have nothing to do with one another so
yeah
and for all the right reasons i said let
me get this straight some democrats want
american citizens to have a vaccine
passport to travel freely within the
united states what is this website he's
using rumble why isn't why didn't he
post this to twitter
what is he doing here with this rumble
website
um i'm assuming rumble is like a youtube
alternative because they all they banned
all these guys love that probably it's a
it's a canadian online video platform
okay so all these guys got banned on
youtube for like covered misinformation
love that
yeah
anyway he uh the description by the way
is coveted passports are just another
way that the government is trying to
control you again it's like pro what is
this weird control conspiracy theory
but not an id to vote i call them
because that's exactly what it is i mean
think about it you
need a vaccine passport you need an id
to be able to travel freely within
america as an american citizen this is
again he's he's oh he's so over
exaggerating we're not you don't need a
vaccine passport to travel freely
nobody's saying that you just can't go
to a [ __ ] dodger game
right it's like you can't it's like
nobody's setting up checkpoint
interstate checkpoints dude that's not
even that's never happened before
yeah i i'm assuming what this is coming
from is when people were discussing this
one more saying that the airlines would
be
that's up to them
right that's where and hey it's where
the big contradiction and all of this
comes from and if you want to socialize
a uh
an airline so that a government owns it
then you're socialist bro you're stuck
in a [ __ ] hole
you literally need to just shut the [ __ ]
up
because companies have a right to make
that decision
that's your whole ethos you [ __ ]
[ __ ] except that they are pushing on
the left you need that
but you don't need enough
you know he watches uh videos of his dad
and looks himself in the mirror powerful
nuclear arsenal in the world someone
who's on a daily basis making trillions
literally can't even listen to him he's
such a [ __ ] and he's in a jungle or
some show like what what is this video
so
odd it's just backyard probably he likes
me
can't get over how he's trying to
imitate his dad yeah
oh and then if you guys want to just
unrelated but super funny don jr if you
want to know how desperate times have
gotten
uh he's perm he's been he's being paid
to promote jake paul's
boxing match oh my god this video
instagram swipe up
now instagram swipe ups aren't paying
that much money
and don junior's uh um engagement on
instagram isn't that great either so i'm
thinking he got like at most a thousand
dollars for this swipe up
and you know with the vast billions they
supposedly have this really underlies
desperate desperate times for john don
jr
listen to this guys um fighter versus
youtube legend there's been a lot of
smack talking around some of my friends
in the ufc like jorge mouse vidal have
chimed in uh talking crap about ben
askin uh and do you think that jake paul
youtube sensation can take him honestly
pre-order this fight check it out swipe
up now uh it'll take you right to the
page so you can do it because i know
we're going to have some fun on the 17th
with this one it's going to be really
interesting to see what happens this is
some rock bottom this is the president's
son doing triller
jake paul do you think jig ball internet
sensation yeah you've never heard of him
to be honest youtube legend youtube
legend jake paul
accusers easy
he is a legend
i love this person who's like what in
god's name is this
good that is the question man do you
think jake palm i'm excited to watch
that boss remax i'm not gonna lie
go over to don junior's uh instagram
page i'll swipe up to yes i want to live
what day when is that the 17th that's
this weekend i think it's yeah a couple
days i'm excited to find a um
i'm excited to find a you should live
tweet it
guys i can't wait for internet sensation
jake paul
he was kicked out of la and accused of
sexual assault
moved to florida because he didn't want
to wear a mask or get shots
did you see um this thing with don
junior just reminded me did you see the
uh
that
uh his dad is now
doing
wedding speeches like doing toasts at
people's weddings oh at marlborough
margaret so
i did see that is that some kind of like
is he trying to just get people to book
weddings there
well yeah maybe it's advertising but
it's still interesting
the guy who was the president just a few
months ago is he's doing emceeing at
weddings now did the video oh send me
that actually
yeah because he came here he was
supposed to say a few nice words about
the groom and bride
yeah you just the guy's like a robot you
can't turn it off yeah he starts soap
walking boxing about politics
i'll kiss the guys and the beautiful
women and them
can you imagine donald trump crash your
wedding he's to say a few nice words and
he just ends up talking about joel biden
[Music]
there's a wedding band behind you
how's everybody doing tonight all right
you heard about what's going on at the
border oh man oh my lord you gotta build
a wall down there am i right all right
hey you so you heard about what's going
on in china
i'll tell you what nothing gets more uh
china you know he might be much happier
now to be honest because now he like
that's the part that he loved about
being president it's just like wow you
know just happiness is all that matters
now he just gets to do that without any
of the work
i was going to say i'm looking forward
to pirating the jake paul fight on
instagram live
that's the best place to pirate
pay-per-view events for some reason it's
instagram live it's so weird really good
tip
yeah dude um
i remember watching there was like the
conor mcgregor
mayfield fight
and people were streaming it on live
with like a million views
anyway that sounds like um yeah sounds
like a much better way to do it than
how i've done it in the past which is to
go to some really [ __ ] weird website
with the
extension like dot xyz or something i
mean that works you just need like three
layers of adblock
right
[Music]
man it's great it's crazy how all these
pirating websites they figured out how
to like
circumvent adblock in like the most fbi
nsa advanced ways possible caa and
youtube still can't do it
i guess youtube chooses not to
um
are you guys gonna watch that fight do
you guys care about that
i actually do yeah
any prediction
um
who is he fighting
literally like the
bottom [ __ ] tier mma fighter that hasn't
fought in three years like it's so dumb
i wish you would just at least he is a
fighter though so he has like mma not
not a boxer not a boxer mma fighter i
mean jack will probably win then no he's
a record he has a record for being he's
the ufc record for being with the
quickest knockout but he was the one
that got knocked out
five seconds
he's retired as of now yeah he got a
knee right to his left ear and it just
out cold well that's a coveted record
yeah he's not he's not a good fighter
like in terms of the mma he's a
professional fighter though
but he's super out of shape he's way
older than jake it's like
it's like they keep picking fighters
and hyping jake up as a real fighter but
he's such a [ __ ] he won't fight a real
trained athlete so he picks this guy
who's out of shape
retired
wasn't a good fighter to begin with and
then boxes it
exactly well he he was the welterweight
uh champion i don't know
what accolades come with that but was a
former olympia he went to the olympics
yeah he has credentials but he's old now
he's out of shape and he's never boxed
right he's 36 now so you know he i mean
even his last fight with nate robinson
he was a basketball player
oh yeah that was a that was just a
[ __ ] joke yeah he won't do it he
won't fight uh but let's see i hope ben
just because ben does have a lot of cred
athletic credentials but like again jake
is six one and this guy ben astrid is
like five eight i mean he's like a short
dude and jake's six one like he towers
over him i mean that's like such a
ridiculous advantage
and then let alone a 10-year difference
you know what i mean
it's like
the fact that they're even casting this
as an equal fight is is ridiculous and
stupid but hey [ __ ] it that's how jake
wins
well i hope he gets his ass kicked but i
wish he would just fight someone in his
prime just take a boxer in his prime
same age same weight class put him up
against jake jake will get knocked the
[ __ ] out every time well that's why he
won't fight people like like just take
some average fight boxer you know with
the average record
yeah i'm gonna watch it though oh man
i'm interested for free on instagram
yeah oh yeah i'll probably pirate that
[ __ ] do not give them money
i'm not paying for it
do not give jake any money
also they make this [ __ ] so annoying to
pay for because you have to like get the
service and then subscribe it's like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you know what i mean it's
not pay-per-view it's like annoying [ __ ]
where you have to like subscribe to some
platform and you have to give them all
your information i'm not into all that
it's too much work
honestly i'm going to pirate it simply
because it's easier
the m i would pay for it if they made it
easy but they don't so i'm just going to
[ __ ] power it on instagram live you
shouldn't support jake paul
well
what can i do i mean you can steal it
from him
you guys see the video where like jay
gave him a little jab and he didn't
flinch at all yeah
yeah let's watch that
[Music]
i mean you can see their height and
weight difference here on the side
i mean that's a 10-year difference
jake is significantly taller
you didn't even like feel it that was
weird what was that just a quick little
bite
weird
here's the thing though it's boxing i
feel like you know jake has the upper
hand but if it was mma or ufc i feel
like he'd be calm down if it was mma
he'd be choked out in five seconds yeah
but it's boxing boxing is like so
different from mma you know what i mean
it's just totally different i mean these
the mma fighters are they're not like
strikers they're like grapplers and
wrestlers and [ __ ] like that so all of
the all of the discipline that they've
accumulated doesn't account for anything
when you're boxing
right
i think it'll be a boring fight that's
for sure
you know
ben weighed in 19 less pounds jesus
that's not good at all
not really 19 less
it's saying uh right now i'm reading
that he was 170 and jake was 189.
that's why these show fights are so dumb
too because like 19 pound difference
that's insane that's like a whole
different weight class isn't it
yeah yeah those people would never fight
in a real
like league fight
it's just not a fair fight
but there you have it
we don't care
right
uh have you got your have you uh are you
planning on getting vaccinated jake
not really right are you worried about
covet at all
not really right
that makes sense
literally just got tested for it okay
okay that's good
are you gonna wear a mask now that
you're in florida
not really right
are you worried about infecting people
around you
right yeah
so here's the tweet i made
moving on all right we were talking
about this
i just was seeing all these dumb ass and
i says oh i maybe i came a little bit
hot but i was upset okay
a little bit
i said hey because this was trending no
vaccine passport said hey no vaccine
passport [ __ ]
it's not fascism you whiny [ __ ] i mean
it's not fascism
it's just not it's definitively not i
mean it's kind of the opposite of
fascism because fascism is when
government as total control
of private entities and pratt and then
vaccine passports is enforced by private
entities at their own choosing so it's
kind of the opposite of fascists i'm so
sick of people trying to say everything
is fascism and especially people on the
right who are who are who are actually
towing up to the line of actual fascism
it's like
this whole notion of fascism has lost
all [ __ ]
definition
we're trying to prevent people from
dying if you don't want to get a vaccine
that's you're right but i don't have a
right to know that your dumb ass isn't
putting my family at risk at crowded
events
i i continued so if that means you can't
go to a movie theater or a ball game
because you choose not to get a vaccine
then that's your choice but it's not
your right to put others in danger so
kindly stop whining and deal with the
consequences of your poorly informed
decision obviously not
obviously it wasn't going to be received
well by uh
especially when you throw the the
hashtag in there
yeah exactly it was kind of
it's kind of inviting and to be honest
with the hashtag
but i didn't i clicked the hashtag i was
like please somebody's saying be
saying something i didn't see anything
so i was like oh [ __ ] it i'll do it
but i didn't i didn't quite expect the
uh
the vitriol thrown back at me but i
guess i shouldn't be surprised because
it was a pretty
it was not a lighthearted tweet well
this whole vaccine thing has become
the flat and then the latest flashpoint
in the culture war [ __ ] and so so
pretty so [ __ ]
predictable government control
wasn't smallpox vaccine mandated by the
way
uh i mean there's been all kinds of
uh
good things similar to this throughout
history y'all remember smallpox no
because it was [ __ ] eradicated
because the us government forced it on
people
did you get your shots r kelly knew all
about that
do you have your passport fact check me
on smallpox please yeah i'm checking
right now thank you
anyway so that was my tweet now here
comes the misinformation
here comes infowars with a whole segment
about me i swear to god dude their whole
vibe is like they're trying to get me
killed that's why when the fbi showed up
at my house i was like oh it's got to be
connected i'm not saying this guy
actually i am that the way they should
like
you got to see the way they cover me
it's crazy
like they keep showing pictures of me
they're like this is the person to kill
so aggressive but anyway this guy's such
a
goon here we go
yeah this shit's this [ __ ] is wild
honestly
i watched it for the first time last
night because i was kind of trying to
save my reaction i didn't watch the
whole thing i had to bounce when you
said that he accused me of liking to
post pictures of my baby's butt on
instagram did you see that dan
oh
yeah yeah who is the infowars guy oh was
the infowars guy got it i was like oh my
god
what
everybody's a pedophile when they're the
topic of conversation on
infowars anyway let's watch
i'd love i'd still love to this day to
have someone argue that they're pro
freedom
but also they want everybody's idea is
it turned up on your end
i'm i'm maxed everywhere okay their
video is just kind of quiet
i'll turn it up
go ahead
i'll start it over okay
i'd love i'd still love to this day to
have someone argue that they're
pro-freedom
but also they want everybody to take a
vaccine
here i'll make that argument for you
right now
first of all nobody's saying that
everyone has to get a vaccine first of
all your argument on the ground basis is
flawed you're you're you're doing a mega
hyperbole nobody's saying that people
should get
mandated vaccinated okay so
first second of all we don't have
absolute freedom like we can't go kill
somebody we can't go rob somebody we
don't we already don't have absolute
freedom
so this whole notion of freedom he's
talking about it doesn't what do you
mean by freedom exactly
you have to get a license to drive a car
right you have a driver's license
[ __ ] yes
you know what i mean
you have a license for your guns yes
[ __ ] face
like everything in our life is regulated
bro it's not a [ __ ] new concept and
you're already going along with the ones
that you don't mind because you don't
want to drive on the road with a bunch
of [ __ ] that don't know what they're
doing you don't want to get run over by
some [ __ ] 13 year old kid should a 13
year old be able to drive a car no is
that infinity on his freedom
i don't know
he's stealing that
but here's the riff
if you believe in the vaccine and you
believe it works so great
and you get it then why are you still
worried about somebody else who's not
been vaccinated so this is like the
caveman argument where it's like you
oversimplify something so much that it's
almost just willful ignorance it's like
peop there's so many reasons why people
need to get vaccinated and
the whole conservative argument is like
if you're vaccinated then why do you
ever care if other people get vaccinated
and there's like a bajillion reasons
and um they choose not to acknowledge a
single one
for example
okay let's
for example the the um
the vaccination as far as we know is it
doesn't have unlimited uh usefulness
they say at least six months right now
so it's not unlimited
number two the biggest thing we need to
worry about
is
the like we're kind of on a clock
against the virus if we don't eradicate
it
as soon as possible it will continue to
mutate and the fear is that it will
mutate to a point
where vaccinations are no longer
effective against it and then all of a
sudden you've got coven 19 just in
circulation globally like the flu
you're going to end up with
millions of people dying every year
globally
from this new virus that we can stop
right now in its tracks
right
the other thing is that in order to
protect there's people like with can't
going through cancer and stuff like that
who have compromised immune systems who
cannot get vaccinated so peop we all
have a responsible as a [ __ ] society
sometimes you have to work as a society
for the betterment of everybody right
you can't just be a rugged individual
all the [ __ ] time so you have a
license plate on your car right
because we all agreed that that's a good
idea to have a
get a driver's license
um because these people can't get shots
so they're always going to be at risk so
we need to get like 70 of the population
vaccinated to hit herd immunity to
protect everyone who actually can't get
vaccinated because they're either going
through cancer or have some other
compromised immune system issue
so i mean there there's a there's
there's a million reasons and it's
talked about openly you know
it's talked about openly it's not a
secret you literally just have to be so
willfully ignorant to make this argument
in 1901 public health officials in
boston cambridge issued their compulsory
smallpox vaccination order
oh it wasn't forced though
people who refused to get vaccinated
faced a fine equivalent to 150 today
oh man that big government back in the
meanwhile donald trump goes make america
great again
okay well night well 1901 you had to get
vaccinated against smallpox
was that great or no
i think we all enjoy our kids not
[ __ ] dying of smallpox
you know
damn
such a [ __ ]
they just sound smart to people who are
like super ignorant but like st
patrick's day is upon whoa who are you
and that's the big riff in their big lie
every time that they'll never address
because you are either admitting that
the vaccine doesn't work no
no not at all
and you want us to take something that
doesn't work anyway bro you're so
[ __ ] dumb or you're admitting you
just want to force people
you just want to tell people what to do
you just this is the whole thing i just
want to tell people what to do like to
what end why do i [ __ ] care what you
do dude
you're just a bully who wants to tell
people what to do
you want to have a big corporate
government you just have to have a big
government in any state yes exactly and
they'll never admit to either one of
those things ever because these are
dishonest people these are liars these
are frauds these are phonies yeah so
you'll never so now he shows pictures of
me this is why like he shows these
photos of me he goes these are lizers
these are frauds these are phonies
seems like he's putting a hit on me
doesn't it a little bit
how he like you'll see even later he
keeps cutting to me
when he's saying like the most heinous
[ __ ]
it's interesting that you got a bomb
threat against your house uh like two
days later exactly
totally at work
and they'll never admit they're actually
for big government tyranny
yes i'm for big government tyranny like
uh let's say
telling all companies they have to do
one thing
big company it's like these guys they
can't [ __ ] use their brands nothing
makes sense
how is it
okay
anyway
the con is really weird they talk about
us and they come back and talk about it
some more so
just another example
of how leftists are just
intellectually dishonest with themselves
so here's an individual ethan klein he
gets to exist on youtube he gets to
exist on facebook he is to promote
himself on social media
and he knows in in order
from everything
right
so i'm part of the problem because i
haven't gotten banned it has to promote
the big government he has to promote the
big lie
so
so he says that i have to support the
big government because
i don't want to get banned from youtube
bro can i just have an opinion like why
is everything got to be a conspiracy
no he doesn't actually believe this
it's just to support big government
okay bro that he can have his
videos on youtube he says
hey no vaccine passport
curse words by the way i love that they
don't curse on him for us like bro you
literally like
you called this sandy hook shooting a a
fake
job and
you had parents of the sandy hook
victims being harassed to the point they
had to move at his site at a state but
you won't say [ __ ]
talk about virtue signaling
wet ass p word
you really won't say [ __ ] on infowars
that's just so odd to me well this kids
are watching
it's like [ __ ] you you did you are such
a douche
it's not fascism you whiny f words
f word we are trying to prevent people
from dying
female genitalia
oh please you're trying to prevent
people from dying please oh please
there's so there's big lie number one so
first they insult you and use curse
words to
hide their inferior intellect oh wow
[Music]
they give you their virtue signal lie
we're trying to prevent people from
dying
oh
who would want to prevent people from
dying
what is their theory there's almost been
six hundred thousand people dying dead
what is the they all deny that too oh
they said those people would have died
well of course well this is the thing
you cannot have a conversation when you
can't agree on some basic facts
they go kovit's not real it's like okay
well conversation's over
600 000 people have not died it's like
okay well how are we gonna have a
conversation we can't agree on the
premise right
they live in [ __ ] walala land
info loss is more like
huh
infowars info l's and philosophers
uh 563 000 deaths
from covid in the united states
by the way i'd like to go back to when i
first started talking about this and i
said i could see up to a million people
dying from this and everyone thought i
was
insane if you're longer people thought i
was crazy
i mean
it's going to be close to a million by
the time we get out of this man
oh closer than
what almost almost 3 million worldwide
yeah that's dude
dude the united states has had so such a
huge portion of that that's so crazy
it's spiking big time in like um india
and brazil it's about to get really
really bad there
not good corona
yeah okay
okay as uh tens of millions are
murdered at abortion factories and you
don't care about that so sorry that
doesn't work for us okay so i have to
care about one thing for my opinion
first of all obviously we disagree on
the whole notion of
uh fetuses being equated to murder but
let's say we did agree on that i can't
have opinion about this one thing
because apparently you think that i
don't care about this other thing that's
important to you your logic doesn't make
sense bro let's just argue the one topic
[ __ ]
it doesn't work on us
if you don't want to get the vaccine
that's you're right
okay
but i also have a right to know that
your dumb ass isn't putting my family at
risk at crowded events actually no you
don't
that's funny actually you don't have
that right at all
in fact i have that the exact opposite
is true i have the right of privacy
see how that works so it's curse word
complain intellectual dishonesty lie lie
lie
i didn't really understand this he says
i don't have a right to be safe and
public events
you don't have a right to know
that the vaccination status of other
people is basically what they're saying
what he's saying
okay well sure but
the venue has a right to [ __ ] ask if
you're vaccinated as a private business
and then i'll go to those places only
where everyone's vaccinated
did you get your shots he's like i have
a right to infect you
it's my given right to go to large
gatherings and infect
people your privacy
i'm sorry what exactly privacy am i
invading by knowing if you've been
vaccinated bro like come on
you can't hide behind these [ __ ]
it's my privacy okay dude
i'm not asking for a dick picture just
want to know if you have a deadly
contagious disease
my privacy bro i don't want to tell you
if i've been vaccinated okay [ __ ] face
then don't come into the ball game go
home and jerk off and watch it on tv
here's the real intellectual dishonesty
uh-oh
but i continue so if that means you
can't go to a movie theater or a ball
game because you choose not to get a
vaccine then that's your choice but it's
not your right to put others in danger
again
we're not that is my right to put others
in danger
putting others in danger that's your big
virtue signal lie okay so stop whining
and deal with the consequences of your
poorly informed decision but wait a
second
yeah this is what i love he keeps
cutting the pictures of me like here he
is guys go get him hint
as you promote the vaccine by the way
this is the guy that shows the entire
world uh pictures uh
loves to show people pictures of his
baby's butt
this part i was like oh my god
bruh
so he's i guess referring to and let me
look now
i guess he's referring to one instagram
post when theodore was a newborn baby
and i posted a picture of me holding him
and he was naked so you just saw his
butt and i thought it was a cute picture
of me and my newborn son
are you happy with it i sent
so like they apparently dug
deep to find this because it's really
old oh here it is 77 weeks 77 weeks ago
october 20 almost two years ago right
after he was born so i posted this
picture of my newly born baby
and he's trying to insinuate that i'm a
pedophile
can we all appreciate just how [ __ ]
insane this is
yeah it's pretty unhinged
it says a lot more about where his
mind's at
if he had to dig two years and this is
all he could find i think that says
something too they've really done their
research
way worse than that online
yeah
but they agree with all that they're
like no problem without that
you should have talked about the photo
of your ass that's what i was referring
to
no because
they had to go with the baby thing
because their whole their whole shtick
is based on pedophiles and [ __ ]
right so he's going to insinuate i'm a
pedophile based on posting a photo of my
newborn baby two years ago
bro i cannot the fact he brought that up
blew my mind
you can talk about intellectual
dishonesty right after showing my
picture by the way i mean that's
insanity that's like [ __ ] crazy
i stopped after this so i don't know
where this goes i i was like whoa by the
way this is the guy that shows the
entire world uh pictures uh
loves to show people pictures of his
baby's butt
no context that's it
uh not i wouldn't be into that he's into
that but that's fine
it's fine
what the [ __ ] isn't that so crazy it's
so crazy
like what
god look at this guy why did you even
bring that up i mean what's that got to
do with anything
he gets to put his videos on youtube he
knows he's not that talented so he has
to be on youtube and he has to tell them
wait we're talented to you [ __ ] wait
i'm not talented so i'm on youtube why
are you so desperate to get back on
youtube
you guys are [ __ ] crying
to be able to post on youtube again
big corporate lies to get promoted
on youtube yes yeah youtube promotes me
a lot that's aside from the point
because i'd love i'd still love to this
day to have someone argue that they're
pro-freedom
but also they want everybody to take a
vacation freedom oh this is from the
beginning this is i'm pro-freedom
this guy's a [ __ ] pure chaos baby
let's go
pure freedom for the world
[ __ ] middle school mentality
i'm pro-freedom
their argument is so narrow and so
ignorant you have to be living in like
the smallest darkest box in the world to
actually think what he's saying is
interesting
you believe in the vaccine and you
believe it works so great believe in and
you get it then why are you still
worried about somebody else who's not
been vaccinated so this was this was the
clip from the beginning i already
addressed yes and that's the big riff
every time that they'll never address
because you are either admitting that
the vaccine doesn't work nope
and you want us to take something that
doesn't work anyway
or you're admitting you just want to
force people
you just want to tell people what to do
you just want to have a big corporate
government what's that
nanny state
what's their narrative on the vaccine
are they um
george soros microchip or are they for
sterilization i heard a clip of alex
jones saying that hiv is in this vaccine
the hiv virus is in this vaccine the hiv
virus is in this vaccine don't you
people understand that
so they're giving us all aids
yeah it's just it's not safe he doesn't
know why but it's not safe
hiv is in this vaccine
[Music]
we're selling our own vaccine against
the covet virus it has a it has a
ground-up sawdust uh ant droppings and
uh caterpillar uh juice it's not funny
did you guys hear about puppetgate from
alex jones oh my god
so howard stern has this alex jones
puppet and i couldn't believe what i was
hearing
so so howard stern has this puppet of
alex jones
and he does these bits where he has alex
jones impersonator
calls in as alex jones they're really
funny really good
and then a newspaper
quoted
it's super hard to wrap my head around
but like he was like oh fake nudist
media said i said this but it was a
puppet on howard stern show that said
this but then they play the clip they
said the puppet said the exact it was
verbatim what alex jones said
oh they were yeah
which is really funny because when i
heard it on howard stern i was like man
the writers are brilliant like how they
it's so funny and outlandish
but this it's verbatim what alex jones
says on his show that's fantastic
so he goes oh they quoted the puppet but
the puppet was verbatim quoting what
alex jones actually said
he can't even keep it straight what he's
saying it's a [ __ ] al he's such i
think so transparently a grifter at this
point like
i i actually do think that there was um
some integrity to what he was trying to
do like 20 30 years ago
but um
it's just like anything has just been
dissolved and you're just following the
money exactly they turn the freaking
frogs gay slinging [ __ ]
like you said snake oil like just it's
all just a way to get you worked up
so you're fearful of something and then
he sells the solution you know
the vaccine has uh hiv in it anyway go
to infowars.com
shop and we are selling our own vaccine
ladies and gentlemen
it has a donkey seaman alex jones spit
and uh
the pubic hair of a deceased uh covet
victim we put all that in a bottle we
shoot it up right into your veins it's
proven to kill cover in five minutes
okay
don't trust big government go to
infowars.com we cook it in my basement
not fda approved
don't trust the fda
yeah can you get that sound bite of him
going it has a dna it has hiv in it
which is
i guess it's made from it like i don't
know it doesn't have hiv in it by the
way well i'm i'm assuming it's like
everything that he talks about based on
a misunderstood grain of truth a grain
of truth that's been misinterpreted or
either
i think the truth is that they
they figured out this really
amazing technology
from from aids research decoding the
mrna yeah vaccines or whatever it's not
funny yeah i mean you can it's just
depending on how you
frame things you can make anything sound
like that yeah all that like
aren't most vaccine like it wasn't the
smallpox vaccine you're injecting
smallpox yes right so deactivated so if
you say it like this was like oh you're
they're going to inject you with
smallpox it's
kind of true that's technically true but
it's not really giving you all the
information you need oh we have a howard
stern clip from it here yeah i have a
timestamp to alex jones nice
our alex puppet tell you you got to take
these vaccines to live your life you
guys used to be able to get on a plane
and then they tell you later
and it's got hiv in it it has hiv in it
it has hiv in it it has hiv in it they
want forced inoculation of the
gastrointestinal which has the hiv
is just popping yeah
it says the same thing verbatim
so when i heard this i was like man the
writers are so good with this alex jones
puppet i had no idea they were saying
verbatim what alex was
howard howard said the same thing he's
like damn i thought you guys were
writing this [ __ ] i was giving you all
this credit for writing this amazing
content
from post-human world infowars.com
yeah
so let's try to make it seem like the
media is just trying to make him look
bad like he never said that's so funny
it's [ __ ] amazing
god these guys are such grifters you
guys
puppet
yeah he called it puppetgate
what's going on with the deaf or like
the uh all the lawsuits like oh yeah he
he appealed it and it was thrown out i
think he's [ __ ] to be honest with you
i think he's gonna get his ass handed to
him in court
didn't he appeal to the supreme court
and they rejected to hear it i think so
last update i see about it is in january
of this year so i guess it's all it's
all still working its way through the
courts right now i hope they take his
ass hopefully take the pants off his
[ __ ] legs
so heinous dude what he did to those
families
yeah i'm seeing that supreme court
denied it denying to dismiss the suit
yeah that was a recent update
uh oh they're taking away his freedom
freedom for the world yeah exactly
dude they don't know what even freedom
means it means one thing one day and
another next that's what i was saying
earlier when he was like
you're not pro-freedom it's just like
what does freedom mean that that's like
too nebulous we already don't have total
freedom so you need to define that same
thing with um fascism
it's like did fascism is kind of like uh
it has a lot of definitions right and so
they use it just like to mean we don't
like that guy
yeah i mean there's not freedom for the
world there's like a library's worth of
books written
analyzing what exactly fascism is it
it's also a nebulous concept exactly
kind of different from place to place
where it's existed and so
you know
calling a vaccine passport the
definition of ashism is um
i don't know there's a lot of people
that have spent a lot of time
yeah it's insane nothing is the
definition of fascism
do you have a complicated government
system
and they'll never admit to either one of
those i need
oh yeah i turned it down thanks ever
because these are dishonest people these
are liars these are frauds
so they'll never admit that the vaccine
doesn't work
and they'll never admit they're actually
for big government tyranny
and so you get an idea of what these
people are like and i don't really care
everybody does their thing and if you're
into like zero iq you know low intellect
entertainment then that's fine again i
don't really care to each his own
but he knows he's a no talent hack that
can only exist
and make a living if he's allowed on
youtube and being promoted on youtube by
the way do you notice what they just did
there they show us
me and my wife
and they show our twitter handles
they're like giving everyone all the
access they need to harass us yeah
they're doing what they do i mean
thankfully nobody [ __ ] watches this
[ __ ] anymore
yeah i mean it has especially when alex
isn't on it's like who the [ __ ] is this
guy
yeah can you imagine paying for this
at least alex jones is [ __ ]
entertaining at least he's a meme no
yeah totally exactly alex jones is
really entertaining
i will say the images and videos they
use of you guys though you look very
friendly
like it's better than the commentary
channels do like in both the photos they
use you guys are smiling and stuff
that's right
yeah yeah the commentary channels they
always go like
make this picture i mean for like three
years ago
right look how sinister he is
that's true looks like we're having a
good time at least we're happy
to each his own
but he knows he's a no talent hack that
can only exist
and make a living if he's allowed on
youtube and being promoted on youtube
love to see somebody answer the question
if you love vaccines so much again if
you think vaccines are going to protect
you and your family then
i spoke too soon
oh i got it
it what
and that's when they'll go and that's
when they'll start to dabble with their
totalitarianism
all this stuff that big lie if you're
vaccinated it shouldn't matter
dude just i'm not responsible for
educating you bro like literally just
google it
but here's the problem google's part of
the conspiracy you you know what you're
immune to learning things
because like even presented with the
information you'll dismiss it as a big
lie
i don't know how they exist because like
you choose to believe some information
you choose not to believe other
information their world is so confusing
and so it goes on
whole fines this is erasmus and poll
paul finds almost half of americans want
vaccine passports
so 44 of them that'll go up anyway
alex are infowars ladies and gentlemen
this guy
um
he's considered part of the alt-right
not surprised i'm not surprised he
didn't mention that i'm jewish maybe he
was trying his hardest to show it in the
photos you know without saying it
he's like please pick up on this please
pick up on this we should return the
favor and show his twitter handle oh
wait
he doesn't have a twitter handle he got
banned of course
no wonder they have such a chip on the
shoulder
yeah i mean
you know
abe you have a tinfoil hat did you want
to say something
well he made some good points i i kind
of understand a little bit where he's
coming from
you better take that hat off dude
scrambling your brain
there's another guy i guess this is a
like a famous comedian sam tripoli i
don't know who he is famous
that's nice of you
i've never heard of him but apparently
he's like
yeah okay mid size
say midsize midsize
um he went on a rant too about my tweet
on a so-called
er our people with brian callan
um i'm never talk
i have no pro i mean i
except that he was accused of essay but
i don't know i don't know brian callum
personally i don't know anything about
him but this guy's a real [ __ ]
[ __ ] like holy god and then he even
see he says he even wants to fight me
i don't know what's with these gorillas
what are you talking about dude what do
you mean you want to fight me
what world are we living in
look how many disposal likes it's gotten
three thirty thousand i mean that is
blatant misinformation
three 000 retweets
um yeah i i uh
look man uh this isn't brian talking
this is sam talking ethan i'll fight you
for charity i've said that why do you
want to fight me
can we just like ha what
can't you just google some information
instead of wanting to fight me
how does that resolve this conversation
i love that
i love that it's just so ape-minded
this though i said i've said that this
is going i wonder how many times he's
done dmt
be something that is i wonder if he's
ever spent 10 minutes in i wonder what's
the longest you spent in a deprivation
tank
if he's fully enlightened yet or not
your your freedoms whether or not
brian's not on board with this guy's
rant it doesn't make any sense but
anyway shout out to sam tripoli who by
the way
he it's sam go honestly his whole grant
is kind of incoherent and weird he's
very confused about what fascism is
dudes and pointy helmets goose stepping
who is ethan kline i don't know he's on
that yeah it's it's a lot but one good
thing i want to shout a point out about
sam tripoli
is that um
bobby lee crashed his car into him his
on purpose
so
i don't know if you guys remember bobby
this happened shortly after the gatsby
when he crashed the gatsby
and he crashed into uh sam's uh car and
he had a total meltdown
he
bro you are so whiny
come on bobby lee crashes guard do you
do not find that funny at least a little
bit
like this you're at a comedy club and
you're not laughing about bobby lee
crashing into your [ __ ] car like how
unfunny can you be dude like these [ __ ]
i don't know if that's fair
that's hilarious bobby lee crashed into
his car did he do it intentionally
bobby says he did oh bobby said he did
yeah he later said he did on his show
no but he was wrong he rolled into it it
wasn't like
like he he just had it on drive and he
didn't hit
the brakes you wouldn't be pissed did
somebody hit your car i would be pissed
but it's also funny that bobby lee
crashed into your parked car
and the parking lot of a comedy club i
mean come on it's hilarious all right
fair enough i mean yeah i'd be a little
pissed let me crash my gatsby i wasn't
mad about that
my gatsby probably cost as much as this
guy's car
not the flex but i'm just saying i mean
gatsby's like four thousand dollars i
mean
you know what i mean
i'm not a foot model
this guy's such a [ __ ] whiner sam
tripoli
also it's not like he has like a really
nice car the other thing so i can get
why bobby and his uh
like what he's got you know like what
i mean
oh he's got like a is that a mercedes or
maybe he's just a nice car i can't tell
regardless
it's hilarious
you can be angry and amused right i mean
come on
sure yeah
what
he uh i think it was like the first time
i ever met him he smacked me as hard as
he could in the back of my bobby lee
yeah and like i was pissed at the moment
but now i find it [ __ ] hilarious
i was surprised he did that i remember
he slapped you and you were saying to me
after the show that he slept that he
like got you good yeah he's like oh
you're so sexy i like your hair and then
just wham
as hard as he [ __ ] could like i saw
that yeah kind of an [ __ ] yeah this
kind of that that i don't like
i i find it somewhat common now you want
to know gorilla brain or you want to
know uh joker brain bobby you lose joker
brains definitely
yeah i love bobby so i'll uh i'll tip my
joker brain is crashing your car into
someone else's for a laugh
but he couldn't have done it to an
unfunnier [ __ ] so we love him for
that
bobby knew
bobby's like i'm paying for it
dude this car is already all [ __ ] up
well it
[Music]
yeah he crashes all the time yeah he has
a prius
so he's like man you know but anyway
here's bobby talking about how anyway
bobby said on his podcast he did it on
purpose which i was like oh my god dude
you're crazy because he he later
admitted that he crashed the gatsby on
purpose too
uh which i thought was so loud the next
thing i see in the corner of my eye is
this prius just rolling and bobby's
outside of it and he's literally not
even in the car drag the car as if he
can stop stop it with his street of
course it just slowly started crashing
the soundtrack it hit his car one month
car bombs you've never done a car bomb
before so you were physically outside of
the car
and your car you it was on drive and you
just left it driving into sam tripoli
and he
freaked yeah i mean naturally [ __ ] i
mean
i'm did you
did you see this that everybody no you
from inside the building anyway
[ __ ] hilarious
guys such a good i like to smell
horrible things
what's the guys act like have you ever
seen sam tripoli
his act yeah i watched some of it for
the show and i was telling uh dan it's
like middle eastern i'm sorry um midwest
suburban dead like corny
wasn't he trying to bring like rock and
roll back like an androidized clay thing
i thought yeah we looked up something
and he
his
show in the 2000s was like
it's comedy but with an edge we've got
strippers there and we've got uh yeah
baby rock and roll you guys remember
when rock and roll was about tits and
cocaine [ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ] hilarious also he's very
outspoken kind of like libertarian dude
but i did see that he did a uso tour in
afghanistan which is pretty ironic in my
opinion so
shout out to shout outs family anyway
peace and love shout out to the families
that's my whole thing
you know that's my infowar
i wonder if sam tripoli has a wiki feat
doubt it sorry dude not bit not big
enough deal
sam tripoli wikipedia passport nope nope
hey sam
shout out to your [ __ ] family bro who
even are you
wikifeet sam tripoli men not a single
match pathetic pathetic
you know he's a spaz when the infowars
clip was a lot more calmer than his
right
yeah
that's true man
well the infowars guy at least was
coherent i could respond i couldn't even
respond to this guys because he was like
that's the definition of fat that
happens
goose stepping in pointy hats
um
anyone else's wiki feet we need to tank
before we move on
i think we got everybody no i think we
got it we got it covered
oh i heard that wait so i heard where
there's a wiki feed takeover um
little wiki feat update
let me check the top ratings because i
heard there was an interesting movement
there
really i want to smell feet uh yeah have
you been toppled
no
that's not okay
someone took a b spot here let's see
celebrities
um sight rating sort by
rating
so number one ethan klein thank you
peace and love almost a seven out of
five that shouldn't be possible but it
is moses
oh my god so that's the new thing is
moses is number two now
no way that's so funny with only four
pictures too a six out of five
wow stay blessed my friend
look at that dude that had to have taken
some coordinated effort to boost yeah i
never even
this has nothing to do with me
there's some renegade foot soldiers yeah
there's some um
it's the
the foot fairies oh that's uh trisha's
gang right yeah okay i'm glad she's on
board finally though
took some convincing now she's got her
foot fairy army oh god god forbid there
ever be a civil war
no god
daddy let there never be a civil war on
what keep feet
daddy
[Applause]
daddy that'll be it that'll be the
bloodiest civil war in uh world history
have we looked at what tricia's score is
the thing on the women's side is that um
oh it doesn't show you the actual score
for something yeah i don't know why yeah
it's weird
so ethan klein number one thank you
peace and love and then klite so wait
what happened to you ab you're not even
on here
they removed me and put me back it's so
weird
like i always be i'm removed and then
yeah but do you still have a high rating
you're just off the leaderboard or what
yeah i think it there was like a coup
and like ian and uh zach tanked it a
little bit but
you guys did you guys let a foot cool
against ab when was i a [ __ ] part of
this what
oh are you not part of it okay sorry
what did you do ian i didn't do anything
i'm not i'm not doing this
you're like mussolini you're like
paranoid foot dictator i'm like
switzerland i don't know what they're
talking about
are you a paranoid foot uh dictator aby
no i i'm glad to be off the site
how do you spell is it abdullah or is it
a b they smell a b but it's like weird
the way they spell it they put like a
period in between or something i can't
even find it right now oh you can't even
find your own page yeah i can't find it
oh man you got nuked
who you kidding huh
this [ __ ] is so funny man i
i'm endlessly entertained by this i'm
sorry it's so funny to me
and people keep going back and finding
more and more foot picks
has anyone from the website like reached
out to you or anything never i see a hot
foot pick right here in the gutter
i've been trying to get in contact with
them but they just will not respond to a
photo really why are you getting in
contact oh you want to maybe talk to an
admin
yeah or something because we i think we
planned something like a little bit ago
where we wanted to have a person from
them call in
maybe they want to just stay neutral
they don't want to show
bias yeah
yeah their traffic's probably way up now
that the foot armies have begun
i'm surprised they've let it go i i
would have expected the the people the
proprietors of wikifeet to be way more
serious about this and think that we're
like trolls we're not trolls though
people love my feet
i want to smell feet i mean seven out of
five bruh
actually i found myself zach past me
zach patched you
no
how's that possible i was like almost i
was like a six at one point oh so your
your rating just went down bro they
didn't remove you you just got you just
you don't have i think he tanked his own
rating
i mean i got to out him a little bit
here he he was
genuinely afraid that the audience was
going to vote him higher than you and
get you in trouble
[Music]
you thought you were going to pass me on
wikipedia listen listen as a troll one
but two he thought yeah he didn't
actually think that his feet were better
he thought that the audience to control
you
would vote him higher than you so that
you would get mad at him that was like
his theory
listen there's more to that dan went in
the discord and said let's troll ethan
get a b to number one and i start
freaking out i'm texting dan like you
[ __ ] said that i don't think i said
that yo you're somebody's to own up is
there a foot mutiny here you better
speak up now before i find out
i think
i think he was getting up there he was
like number two and i may have made a
comment that said it would be funny if
he passed
i didn't encourage people to go do that
in a panic because that would have been
funny that's basically encouragement dan
if you say oh wouldn't it be funny it's
like it wouldn't be funny that would be
funny that's encouragement
i mean i it's facts it would be funny if
abe got higher than you wouldn't be
funny at all you know
i like maybe your opinion yes
i was coming back keep it to yourself
who authorized you to give orders to the
foot army i didn't this was not an order
it's an insinuation if independent
actors wanted to uh do so wait zach has
a high score zach wow i'm out of four
nine oh nice congratulations thank you
i haven't seen your foot picks wait zach
oh is it zachary
it's zach lewis it's in the discord i
sent lewis oh you sent me oh here it is
i got you now you're living
wow i saw you guys all putting up feed
pics just for i'm not on there that's
the eg podcast logo this is some quality
that's funny those are some well-managed
oh my goodness wait so you you did take
pictures with this intention zach no no
no no no here's what happened what well
it's fine he's just
he's just not being like hey guys
wouldn't it be funny on discord if
everyone gets ethernet one
that's not good with you bro i wouldn't
[ __ ] you overlapping i know it's
actually loyal foot lieutenant who would
the [ __ ] would do that hey being dan
apparently
i pulled over my car and i called dan in
a panic i'm like what are you doing to
me
he did he said
so maybe davey is loyal and dan's trying
to fight i was freaking out i was
freaking out dude
[Music]
i swear to god on my mother's life i
tried self-reporting myself so dan is
the [ __ ] mutinist
trying to throw a so dan somebody just
said that they just found evidence that
exonerated me wait wait oh you did
what'd you find
number one on the site to troll ethan
challenge
how [ __ ] dare you even try to
how dare you even [ __ ] who authorized
you to make such a statement on the
discord is not loyal that is insane
i guess i guess it was that way to me
and be like oh i never i honestly just
didn't really remember this was months
ago but yeah i'll own it i don't care
hey the statute of limitations doesn't
end on this type of [ __ ]
i'm going to try to find my messages
it still would have been
it still would have been funny maybe i
believe you thank you
dan is the [ __ ] dan you better check
yourself right
someone says should i make ethan's
rating lower
you says well you said nah just pump up
abs so you did have some
sense of humanity no i didn't want you
to get tanked i just thought it would be
funny if abe passed you because they
would because it objectively would be
i don't see what's funny about that
i genuinely don't
why don't you put show your feet right
now dan no
i don't want to be on there but you
think you're about quick you just want
to [ __ ] with it
you're like littlefinger bro
you're the yaga of the situation dan oh
wow look at that
oh a nice reference do you guys hear
about us sherbot usher paying strippers
with oh my god
he's the best
he's awesome
this is straight schrute bucks from the
off
right and these are like high quality
fakes too i was like man he i wonder if
you can get
probably go to jail like this seems
serious these are like really high
quality fakes they are i don't think you
can go to jail for i mean it's it's
obviously not
real but they're spending it they're
giving it to strippers
this one lusher las vegas for residency
oh
it was it seems like this was uh
i know this is a promotional thing for
gotcha okay
they left it
as tips so they tried to explain
themselves because everyone was like yo
usher why are you leaving fake [ __ ]
tips with your money on it
i guess one of the girls who works there
posted this she said the money does not
have a trade in value whatsoever hey
that's funny i love that she had to say
that
no no go to the post office they'll uh
they'll redeem that
don't y'all think he should be blasted
on social media for this [ __ ] i mean
kind of i don't think you should be
giving that out at a strip club even if
you did tip
it's a little corny bro
what if it just got accidentally mixed
in with his uh with his normal cash and
he didn't realize it that's what they
say but i think they were making a i
think they were making a rain usher
bucks
i really do
especially some of his homies they're
like here take some usher bucks baby
they thought it was hilarious they
probably so usher himself was giving
these out
it's unclear i'll read i'll read what
they said
apparently him and his whole crew went
to a strip club
and they spent a lot of money
and they also spent a lot of usher bucks
as tips
so i mean you know they're they're dark
in there you know you can't see yeah it
looks like real money that's what i'm
saying yeah yeah maybe it just you know
i'd rather see
than i'd rather see an usher than a
franklin i mean it's more badass i think
i'd rather see a franklin
i mean what kind of promotional thing is
that either like who's gonna be ha
nobody's happy to get fake money
hey dude here's a hundred it's just a
picture of usher what am i supposed to
get excited about his show
i want a hundred bucks
everybody's disappointed about this
promotion
be excited if your face was on a hundred
dollar bill
yeah but not as excited as if you just
got a hundred dollar bill
yeah i i feel like this one might be
more collectible
interesting it might be a good segment
send zach to strip club with some ethan
bucks ethan why don't you just start
paying zach and uh ethan bucks since
he's so into the idea yeah yeah you have
to pay him except ethan bucks instead of
payment yo so savit 21 savage made his
own funny money
he said y'all ain't the only ones
getting that usher money oh he got us
your fault he's got usher bucks damn
he's rich as [ __ ] boy
that's got to be at least 10 g's in
usher bucks
what what is the value of one usher buck
it's like a penny or something like a
shrew buck is it a true buck was it one
shrew buck like a penny or something it
was less than a penny i think
it's awesome
shout out to them
and their family i saw you had something
up ian did you bail on that i thought it
was funny
oh what this the i was wondering
you want to ask if you can receive your
your salary in fupa box this showed up
in an envelope from payroll i was kind
of confused
yeah i mean no that's that's that's
totally redeemable that looks great did
you just whip that up real quick
yeah
[Music]
if you go to a taco shop if you go to a
outdoor
shopping center late at night you could
probably spend that
yeah
or a dark strip club apparently or dark
strip club
here baby i'm gonna make it rain i just
love the idea of them going in with fake
money with usher's face
oh you know what time it is
okay i know we don't have much how much
time we got left here very little
actually yeah ethan has to ethan has
somewhere to be today so we have kind of
i can be a little late i think i can i
can go over a little bit we have about
10 minutes
so if we got out like a quick story we
were planning on doing a rock and roll
trivia yeah i don't know if we have time
for that
and dan as they've been stepping to each
other
and i'm actually quite curious
last week they got a little bit tangled
up when dan said hey you're not the only
one who knows rock and roll trivia
around here
but zach is the rock and roll guy
i mean he does have those glasses that's
i've
faced to be honest
here's the thing though zach zack what
is your age
i'm 23.
dan
uh i'm 33.
so that's 10 years more of experience
and knowledge that counts for a lot in
this world
so well it's a tough one that's it i was
talking a lot of [ __ ] last week but but
i do anticipate zach being an admiral
opponent we uh i mean him and i talk
rock stuff all the time together we do
you know i didn't know you're such a
rock and roller dan i thought you were
like into like nd [ __ ] dan knows a lot
he he knows he knows a lot i have to say
he does
he did dan is very smart yeah i just
didn't know you're a rock and roller or
do you just know about all music
probably more that but uh no i mean rock
is hard wow we've got a little bit of a
baba booey situation i mean rock is my
uh
that's my first love what can i okay
let's get let's get some sample
questions because i really want to know
who do you guys think's a favorite to
win this ian and ab i can't decide
you gotta go zach i think it all depends
on the questions
well
i don't know i mean of course but like
come on don't sit on the fence what was
zach what was zach pulled out something
yesterday on our meeting what was it and
we were like why do you know that i
asked him about creed
oh yes
i actually well first of all i knew that
too
oh okay i was the one who
who named the lead singer of creed
actually in that conversation okay when
when scott when they were stopped creed
what was the ban that they went on to oh
you said it yesterday i don't i honestly
i don't remember okay so i don't give a
[ __ ] about creed
let's ask some questions let's see
i mean do we want to do we want to get
into this now yes i want to know
i want to i want to test the waters
okay i want to say zach but i'm thinking
dan it's just his wisdom and euro diet
eurodiciousness which i doubt is a word
is gonna know these just because he's
been around longer but zach he's got
that young brain he's got that joker
brain he needs a rock roller he i i
think dan might have been to more
concerts than i have but
i mean i i study liner notes for fun
so
what is liner notes that's like the
creative no it well sort of it's the
anything that's written on the uh
the inside fold of the you study the
inside folds for fun pretty epic claim
yeah
well i got news not only do i also read
those but
but
when i was in college an entire wall of
my apartment was covered from ceiling to
floor with liner notes i extracted them
from everything from every album i ever
worshipped liner notes yeah so okay
that's okay that's fair okay
let's let's just here let's how long
we've been going let's stop at the two
hour mark because that's where youtube
cuts us off
uh we've been going for
about an hour 40-ish okay
let's get some few questions in i just
want to taste the waters there a little
bit go ahead again
test
i want to dance in the water i will
taste the water if i want to
wait how are we doing this are you going
to ask ian's going to be in cut i think
when we did the simp off i asked one
person a question if they got it wrong
the other person can steal they can
alternate
so right okay
okay uh let's start with zach let's
let's start with zach okay zack which uh
which band originally toured under the
name mookie blaylock
keep playing do we have some kind of
game show music
was actually gotta what well he was able
to get a multi brain
i have no [ __ ] idea literally none
dan you got any idea on this one
i have sort of an idea but
mookie blaylock
you can try to answer if they get it
wrong it'd be i have no idea about any
of these i don't know this one
okay well you don't you could so dan do
you have an answer to this i have a
guess go ahead
i think it might
i think it might be pearl jam
is that your final answer
i guess i i think it it's a grunge band
i do know that
uh it is pearl jam yes oh wow
baby wait how did you know that dan i
just i've heard it
i don't know murky what would they call
murky poo lock it's it was the name of a
uh like a baseball player oh basketball
huh
wow
fair enough
pearl jam trivia that's gotta hit you
hard zac yeah he's a way bigger grunge
fan than me so i'm actually surprised
you didn't know that i knew i didn't i
was not confident on pearl jam at all
though i gotta say let's go ahead let's
go ahead uh with another one uh ian
okay so this one's for dan yeah
uh
ringo starr only wrote two songs for the
beatles by himself
what were those two songs
octopuses garden
is one
that one i know
i know he's saying yellow submarine i
don't know if he wrote it um
it could
no maybe it was the closer on white
album the good night um what is it
called goodnight
this is a deep deep cut this is a deep
cut octopus guards
octopus garden for sure
i'll go with um
i'll go with the one from the white
album although the name of the song is
kind of escaping me i think it's called
good good night
good night good night or something like
that
that is incorrect oh that is these are
very hard wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait do you have to say you got to give
zach a chance to steal that yeah go
ahead zach octopus garden um
i want to say
little help with my friends that's not a
beatles song is it what they freako
didn't write that
that's definitely like john lennon what
he's saying is why he's saying
then joe cocker covered it well wasn't
the question if he wrote yeah yeah the
question is
which two did he write yeah octopus
garden
i want to say yellow submarine i want to
say that
god
what's the right answer it is don't pass
me by oh
and off the start right yes so okay
these are very different yeah these are
hard these are hard dude what the [ __ ]
so how does that work is there partial
points
i think you get a writer you don't yeah
dan is one up one point uh go ahead zach
you guys are talking about your
line or no doctorates
yeah true exactly
all right okay um
try to pick an easier one damn yeah yeah
okay this one's for uh
no this one's this one's for young
zachary right right uh in 1999 garth
brooks briefly took on the alter ego of
a rock musician this game that one's
easy oh that one's easy okay no but i
love it fair enough fair enough okay so
we're 1-1 go ahead dan
that one's like even a meme on the show
yeah that's true it is
okay
okay dan which singer is credited with
popularizing stage diving
huh
uh oops i meant to cut to myself uh
popularizing stage diving um
probably iggy popped exactly confident
i'm gonna say iggy pop
it is iggy pop oh okay baby see i don't
know the [ __ ] iggy pop is
nice job dan did you know that zach i
did um
yeah yeah okay definitely no two one now
we're getting now we're getting moving
he was the original uh
rambunctious you know performer on stage
cutting himself all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
2-1 dan go ahead zach
okay uh
zach which famous musician inspired the
deep purple song smoke on the water uh
frank zappa and the mothers of invention
yes wow that's another tied up now now
we're getting moving here
now we're getting moving two two damn
go ahead
i want to keep it balanced here and find
something
not too difficult
in the song you have to give that mama
you had to give zach the zappa one
that's not fair okay okay dan prior to
elvis who is widely considered uh the
father of rock and roll
there you go oh little richard
yeah
little richard or
um
chuck berry oh chuck berry
fair too couldn't you throw jerry lee
lewis in there too i mean it's all kind
of i mean all right let's get let's give
dan the point three two i want to see
what i'm waiting for is a dan miss exact
grab that's what's gonna throw this game
all off let's go to zach tie it
up uh zack uh what score did uh anthony
fantano give the latest tool album is
that really a rock trivia platform
that's a [ __ ] question i don't know
and zack definitely knows it because he
was hyper triggered by this
he gave it a four right a lot it was a
four
[Laughter]
okay he was a little questionable
you weren't happy with that rating huh
[ __ ] no i love tool i mean i have the
[ __ ] deluxe package
right here
like but you think you think it deserve
a higher score [ __ ] yeah it's a great
record okay
that question and the chris gaines one
were pretty tailored to zach i i gotta
say
not not i'm not
i'm not calling anybody out here right
i'm just laughing
some excuses while you're still
technically in the league just the same
time
we're very no you are tied but dan has
the advantage here and he is complaining
a little bit
just saying
go ahead okay dan the uh
the group led zeppelin was originally
known as what
the new yard birds
that's correct there you go that's some
rock trivia for you did you know that
zach i didn't know that you did okay
fourth four point stand three point zack
we're let's go this is a close game now
[Applause]
uh
this
let's see this is
uh an easy one
uh let's see he's getting all the easy
ones all right all right i'll give him
again give me even more give your heart
be fair give me your intermediate one
often we're referred to as the first
lady of bass guitar
he played 12-string guitar for sonny and
cher frank zappa the beach boys sam cook
he's got this one for sure any other
soundtracks what is her name
errol
k
that's right
hey
what was her name carol kay she's she
was part of the looked like you're gonna
wreck it up you're like errol king i
think he was just pausing for a dramatic
effect good job
thank you she was part of the uh the
wrecking crew yeah there you go
dan flexing a little bit on his
knowledge
they were uh a studio a set of studio
musicians who themselves were not really
famous but played on most of the iconic
albums from like the 60s through the
early 80s right like yeah i mean they're
all on pet sounds and [ __ ] yep like
look at you two
interesting tied up ian go ahead for dan
uh dan in 1999 this lead singer from a
popular new metal band was named senior
vice president of interscope records
who was it
um
wow my mind is immediately going to one
thing but i feel like it's probably not
right but it was it fred durst it was
frederick
that's the rotating door fred thurs
became a lobbyist
we talked about fred durst all the time
we talked about
did you zack
no i actually didn't know that one wow
dan okay
dan is kind of um impressing me
but still we're zach you have a chance
to tie it up
uh okay uh
which musician's son
uh became drummer for the who in 1996.
zack starkey and then his ringo starr
that's right wow i would not have known
that one so okay
tied up i'm glad that one went to zach
i'm waiting for someone to slip up here
so i can kind of name like a ringo
starr's son became the replacement
drummer for the who zack starkey well no
there was one after when they made um
the album after keith died so their
first record back in 81 was the drummer
for the faces
[Laughter]
if this ends up in a tie i have a really
good challenge for you guys really okay
all right well let's see
go ahead this one's for dan
all right dan uh
which pink floyd album was the first
album to ever be played in space
um
well
i don't actually know the answer to this
but i would have to guess dark side of
the moon
yes it was not oh see it
that doesn't i thought it might have
been a quick question go ahead uh zach
yeah zach can steal
i mean process elimination here yeah
there's only so many albums
okay
moon landing 69 i feel like that was a
missed opportunity by whoever was in
space to be honest
did you give the year that it happened
no i didn't
oh i'm just i'm trying to think when
they would have done this
uh
okay
i want
[ __ ]
so he doesn't actually know he's going
to guess what maybe you'll get a lot
i'm thinking about dan hold on
here get dan dan dan
it's not that it's delicate sound of
thunder
that's a missed opportunity right there
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] were they
thinking all right let's keep going now
let's keep going back to dan we're still
tied up
okay dan the uh
the uh original guitarist for fleetwood
mac from their first three albums left
the band in 1971
why did they leave the band
uh
because uh
because of the relationship problems so
he broke up with uh with what's-her-face
right
now original guitarist jeremy spencer is
his name he broke up with what's her
face
because of bad breakups
that's not the answer oh okay ooh zach
sweep it for the win wasn't the original
guitar is peter green
i think you might want to fact check
your question oh
zach coming in with the [ __ ]
fact check
because
stevie nicks
didn't come stephen that's right and
they were a blues band
they weren't a poppy you know seventies
yacht rock oh
exactly so the original guitar peter
green you might want to check your
question on that
why did they break up though let's see
if you if you know let's say well the
band didn't break up he left why did he
why did this guy leave
well i think fleetwood mac wanted to go
in a new direction mick wanted to take
it in a new direction and that's when
they found lindsey buckingham and stevie
nicks
new direction
who they found in sound city recording
studio in
new directions
that seems like a wrong answer he left
to join a cult
that's a new direction
that is an interaction
but i can't give it to you zach come on
now let's get let's get a winner here
back to dan we're at a tie game this is
a nail biting no uh
that was my question originally wasn't
it
no nobody got it right though yeah but
we're still alternating i think it's
next wait
wait is that question
yeah i think it's tied still is it yeah
it's time it's tied
back to dan
wait that was dan's question no that was
my question yeah exactly
yes oh zach's turned my bad you're right
is it back to zach tight game thank you
dan honor among competitors
uh zach where did duran duran get their
name
oh
having some strain on zack's face he's
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't it from a
movie
wasn't it from a movie
[Applause]
it was from a uh
it was from a movie um
i don't remember the name of the movie
it had jane fonda in it i want to say is
like an old like shitty bee sci-fi movie
but oh wait uh
no i don't know i don't know
the old sci-fi movie it was a 1968 film
barbarella yeah
all right back to dan we gotta crown a
winner here we're so close
keep it moving
uh dan can you name at least four
members of the ramones hmm
i mean
no
no zach can you i just i well i don't
want to give any to zach but i know i
can't i know i can name a few but i
can't name force okay
zach
dede ramone johnny ramone
um
those are the two that i knew rick rick
there were there were some later members
wasn't there a ricky ramone
just named him you can't ask in
oh the ian said not quite your mom and
johnny ramone i think this is uh i don't
know
i don't know yeah that's a lot of
ramones how many words there's a lot of
ramones dude yeah there's a lot of
ramones
yeah joey johnny dede tommy marky richie
elvis and cj freaks see we had a lot to
draw from but we couldn't even come up
with those later years of the remains
okay
let's keep it okay all right that let's
do some whose turn is it zax yeah jax
okay go ahead go ahead
uh which grunge bands out of seattle
were nicknamed the big four
which ground bit multiple
metallica
and slayer
i think you misunderstood the question
wait what which grunge bands out of yeah
that's what i said known as the big four
metallica anthrax
those don't sound like grunge bands to
me those are wait what do you know the
big four are known as metal bands
zach that is incorrect
you got you got it
hold on hold on
three times no we kept insisting this i
i did not hear him please please okay go
ahead
and allison chains
pearl jam and nirvana
that's right okay he knew it all right
fair enough you know it
but
we kept trying to help before and when
we were clarifying now we clarified over
and over again
and even as you were answering go ahead
you get the point dan you got the point
tie it up got the point
tie it up dan
oh is he in the lead now no no no no
okay he's tied i'm my bad okay yeah
uh are you sure about that
i give up a point he's up a point
okay wait i thought he was
no we we've been tied this whole time
yeah they've been tired yeah go ahead
it's tied i know that if dan gets this
right gotcha uh all right dan uh in
let's see i'm looking for a good one
in 2009 radiohead released this single
as a tribute to one of britain's last
surviving world war one veterans
uh it was uh
i think it was called a memory of harry
patch
i think that's kill the music yeah
that was right yeah that's right
wow great job
do you know that
zach let's go let's keep it moving it's
it's 208
do we
i think you guys have both proven
yourself worthy competitors here i think
we should end it with the challenge i
was talking about okay what do you got
what you got though usually before the
show we have this bad habit of singing
creed
who can do the best creed
impression
you're gonna get clean
you're gonna be so accurate that we're
gonna get claimed is that what you're
saying yeah uh
zach is like borderline professional
singer
yeah that's not i think we're gonna have
to continue this in our next
yeah i think we might just have to on
wednesday we gotta do some death round
[ __ ] and take it to the streets because
you you guys both are pretty good
i'm impressed for sure thank you thank
you thank you like dan you're a great
competitor you as well zachary you as
well and let's let's think of some death
match for uh next wednesday we can put
this to bed
well anyway
that was fun
i'm actually going to tour a school for
theodore oh oh nice yeah
wow
grows up so fast for a preschool which
is really exciting it doesn't start for
for a bit but we're going to go tour it
so that's awesome i'm excited for him to
go he's going gonna have so much fun
there you're gonna do some crazy uh
what's the uh like the french
advanced learning schools called
monsoory i'm probably saying it horribly
it's just a preschool
montessori right there you go what is
what do they do with the montessori
i honestly don't know but it's it's like
supposedly it's uh
super intense
turns your kid into a genius intense
he's a [ __ ] two years ago i know and
they started really want i just want
them to go finger paint and have fun
fair enough yeah
all right
so uh we'll see you guys on friday thank
you for watching
this big and the words of sam tripoli
i didn't want to say the r word these
days because i know it's offensive to
people but uh a big fat uh what do you
call me a big a stupid r word
from one stupid r word
[Music]
thank you for watching everybody have a
great week see you on friday
[Music]